it is a new year we are officially in
2014 where does time go I don't
understand but as usual at the start of
the year I'd like to tell you guys what
movies I'm most looking forward to that
are coming out this year at the end of
this video I'm gonna be telling you guys
about some of the movies that are coming
out this year that I'm not looking
forward to stay tuned for that but let's
get started now this January there's
gonna be some films that are expanding
that came out late December last year
and very select theaters like a handful
of theaters a lot of people ask me where
my reviews for lone survivor and her
were can't do anything about it hasn't
open in Ohio yet but it will be opening
here soon and I'm looking forward to
seeing those movies and that's really
all I care about in January the movies
that we're going to come out last year
are expanding in January to other
territories besides that January can go
screw itself on February 7th we have the
lego movie now this movie could be awful
it really could be terrible but
something about it looks really smart
and clever and I think the way that they
use the childish humor could actually
bring a strength to this movie and make
it really fun also on February 7th we
have the monuments men directed by
George Clooney with a humongous cast
full of very talented people this movie
was originally supposed to come out in
2013 but according to George Clooney
some of the special effects weren't
finished yet knee wasn't comfortable
releasing it yet that's the story that's
going around the city the city being the
Internet on February 12th we have
Robocop this movie could go either way
just like the lego movie it could be
awful it could be good but even if it is
good it has to be good in the type of
way that Dredd was good where it remade
certain elements of the original and
made it way better but that's tough to
do because the original Judge Dredd with
Sylvester Stallone wasn't really that
good so the remake had it easy
the original Robocop is a very beloved
film by many fans and so this movie has
a ways to go but we'll see how it is on
February 12th we have the next film in
the continuing Liam Neeson dominates the
month of January and February non-stop
you haven't noticed Liam Neeson movies
tend to come out in January and February
taken the gray unknown all January in
February movies apparently those are his
months this movie could also be awful I
mean if you saw taken - you'll
understand why I'm saying that but I
know that Liam Neeson will at least be
fun to watch and it's cool to see him
kick ass
it could be fun but it could really be
stupid though and there is the
possibility that it's going to go that
way but we will see when the movie comes
out
I'm March 7th we have grand Budapest
hotel the next film by Wes Anderson I
haven't really watched much about this
movie I've stayed away from trailers and
images and whatnot because as a
filmmaker Wes Anderson really impresses
me most of the time and so I don't
really want to know much about it I'm
looking forward to it simply because of
the talent involved with it on March
21st we have Muppets most wanted I
really like the new Muppets movie I
thought it was a lot of fun this one has
a different cast though and different
people involved with the different
directors and whatnot of course why do
you go to see a muppet movie the Muppets
and they're in it so it has the
possibility of being awesome on March
28th we have Noah the new Darren
Aronofsky film retelling the biblical
tale of the man in the Ark and all the
animals and his family hopefully it's
gonna be interesting and visually
impressive as a filmmaker darren
aronofsky amazes me with almost every
movie he puts out also on March 28th we
have the raid 2 you know if you guys saw
the raid that was a pretty incredible
action film but it sort of centered
around this gimmick that there was just
this one apartment building and it was
just levels and levels of chaos this
phone looks like it really expands that
idea and goes deeper than that on April
4th we have Captain America the Winter
Soldier obviously I'm excited for this
movie because I'm a nerd and I like
people who wear shiny tights and do
things with superpowers and whatnot and
it's I like that the first Captain
America film was a movie that I had fun
with it was sort of like the first Thor
I enjoyed it it had elements of it that
I thought were entertaining to watch but
there were definitely things about it
that could have been improved
significantly I'm hoping that Captain
America the Winter Soldier does that
because from what I'm hearing it's more
like a spy movie espionage more
realistic and I really like that take on
it and I hope that it succeeds on April
18th we have Wally Pfister's new film
transcendence now wally pfister is the
director of photography for Christopher
Nolan this is his first film that he is
directing it stars Johnny Depp and a lot
of other talented people it's looking
kind of like we have our Nolan jr. here
it's sort of an interesting idea and I
really like the way that the trailer
looks but it didn't really hook me
instantly on May second despite my
thoughts on the trailer and my thoughts
in the first film and the way it looks
like it's going the amazing spider-man 2
still has my curiosity
it doesn't quite have my attention yet
though unfortunately those in Django
Unchained reference and I'm hoping that
the filmmaker Marc Webb can pull off a
really good movie here 500 days of
summer was great I think that he's
learned from certain things that went on
with the first one he'll be more
experienced this time around and I'm
hoping that it is better than first on
May 16th we have Godzilla this trailer
was awesome and Bryan Cranston is in it
and I think that guy this point knows
how to pick a good script I just want to
see a global destruction Godzilla where
it doesn't seem like it's this great fun
hilarious adventure where it actually
seems like what would happen if a giant
dinosaur just appeared and destroyed the
earth it would be horrible so I really
want this film to have that feel to it
on May 23rd we have Bryan Singer's
return to the x-men universe x-men Days
of Future past that what I just said
alone makes me excited for because well
I haven't been too impressed with much
of his films since the x-men films he
did direct to great x-men movies and I'm
hoping that he's able to do that with
this one and I'm really hoping this film
is able to meld those two franchises
that of x-men first class in the
original x-men films and make it awesome
on June 6 we have a movie that looks
like a pretty cool video game starring
Tom Cruise directed by Doug Liman the
guy who brought us the Bourne Identity
now those things is right there I mean I
like video games I like Tom Cruise and I
like the Bourne Identity and I like
Emily Blunt too and she is looking good
in this trailer and I'm hoping that this
movie is awesome now a lot of people
have said it looks like a video game and
they've said that as a way to dis the
movie and I'm like I like video games I
don't really feel like that's a proper
insult most people actually like video
games now yes not all video games are
supposed to be like movies and vice
versa but this movie looks like it
supports that type of fun action and I'm
hoping that it's awesome I love sci-fi
and I love mechs too when used in a cool
way and this movie has you know he's
running in his suit and Tom Cruise is
running and you get to see Tom Cruise
run which is awesome because Tom Cruise
runs really cool but he's also in a
robot suit now and he's running so I'm
totally obviously a nerd for a robot
suit guy running from explosions on July
11th we have dawn of the Planet of the
Apes directed by Matt Reeves and one of
the reasons I'm very excited for this
movie was because I enjoyed the first
one Rise of the Planet of the Apes and I
think that Matt Reeves is a very
talented director and I really think he
can take this in really interesting
directions also it has Gary Oldman and
any time Andy Serkis does
motion capture work for anything I mean
there's only one guy in Hollywood who's
got an Oscar buzz for motion capture
work and that's Andy Serkis and I'm very
excited to see what this film brings on
July 25th we have Jupiter ascending the
Wachowskis new movie starring Channing
Tatum and Mila Kunis I wasn't really
that impressed by the trailer I'm not
really hooked yet but the directors have
my curiosity and that's why I'm
interested in this film because these
guys made the matrix one of my all-time
favorite movies on August 1st we have a
movie that I'm strangely curious about
which is kind of sad because it's a
Marvel movie and I should be more
excited for it but guardians of the
galaxy really is something that I'm
hoping could be totally different in
original which one I've heard of all the
source material and the directions
they've taken the movie it will be those
things I'm just hoping that it works
because the end credits scene in Thor 2
was really frickin weird on August 15th
we have the third installment in a movie
series that is continuing to make grown
men cry each year and that is the
Expendables 3 the first one just felt
like it was trying to be something that
it wasn't the second one really
understood it's just a cheesy action
will be filled with all these people
from your youth and you're supposed to
enjoy watching them shoot and punch
things and it did it fairly well I
thought I'm hoping the third one
continues in that same vein on November
7th we have what is most likely my most
anticipated film of the year and that is
interstellar the movie we don't know
that much about but it strikes by
Christopher Nolan stars Matthew
McConaughey and a whole bunch of people
who are talented it involves wormholes
and time-travel and science fiction
things and I am excited purely for that
I didn't talk much about the trailer
because it kind of be like me just
struggling to figure out something to
talk about for three minutes because it
really wasn't that much in the trailer
but that's the point a teaser teaser
actually comes around that teases people
like it's supposed to without spoiling
everything people get all up in arms
about it but then they all get upset
when the trailer ruins things for them
to internet make up your mind on
November 14th we have a film that I am
interested in purely because I love the
original it's the film that I grew up
with a lot as a kid
the directors of that film haven't
really done hardly anything in the past
few years that have inspired me in fact
they were involved with movie 43 which
makes me like iBook I don't even know
what this movie's gonna be like that
being said Dumb and Dumber to does star
Jim Carrey and Jeff Daniels and that
right there is something to be excited
about on November 21st we have the
Hunger Games Mockingjay part 1
I really like Catching Fire quite a bit
so I'm very excited for this movie even
though they're doing the cliched we got
to cut this last book in the two parts
thing that everything seems to be doing
nowadays on December 12th another film
that I don't know that much about it is
called Tomorrowland it's gonna be
starring George Clooney instructed by
Brad Bird his last film was Mission
Impossible 4
I've liked all of his cartoon films as
well so for that reason I'm interested
in this film despite the fact that I
don't know that much about it that's
something I also like is I don't know
that much about it I like not knowing
that much about this film and on
December 17th we had the final
installment of The Hobbit there and back
again I really enjoy desolation of smaug
it really surprised me because I wasn't
a humongous fan of the first one even
though I enjoyed it it could have been
improved a lot the second one really
improved it and I really had a lot of
funk that second one and I'm hoping the
third one's even better now guys as I
told you there are some movies coming
out this year that I'm not really that
excited about but some people may think
I should be I'm simply not some of those
films are transformers for the age of
extinction why are these movies still
being made it's still directed by
Michael Bay it's a different cast that
could maybe be good but you know what
it's not it's not gonna be different
it's a Michael Bay movie everyone
thought pain and game was gonna be
different it's still a Michael Bay movie
with over-processed saturated colors
boobs and butts and big muscular men and
big wide curved shots where they zoom in
on things it's all the same also the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles or teenage
alien Ninja Turtles or whatever the
world is gonna be I don't care about
that movie what what was it Megan Fox is
April O'Neil what's going on with that
here's a movie that some people are
excited for that I'm simply not and I'll
tell you why sin city a dame to kill for
I really enjoyed the first Sin City film
but they pushed this movie back almost a
year what kind of preparation is that
Robert Rodriguez a year to make it it
was supposed to come out like last year
a year you pushed movie back a year and
Paranormal Activity five yes we have
paranormal activity that marked once
that's the first movie coming out in
January I will have a review for that we
also have another Paranormal Activity
movie coming out why is this what's
going on it's just a giant money-making
franchise that's what it is they make
these movies for $2 like if the opening
weekend of this movie made like five
million dollars it'd probably be a
profit and that's where these movies
keep getting made because they may come
for nothing and people go to see him so
guys I'm sure I missed some things I
looked at a list and tried to get as
many
of the releases down there may have been
some tentative release dates that
weren't on the list that I saw there may
be some films I forgot what are you guys
looking forward to this year as always
guys thanks so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck man eyes
[Music]